hello i'm sasha larkin i'm a captain
with the las vegas metropolitan police
department
here to bring you the preliminary
details as we know them so far
on officer involved shooting number 18
for 2020.
the details as we know them so far this
morning
december 8th at approximately 1 20 a.m
a call for service was received of a
burglary in progress
in the area of tropicana and 215.
as officers arrived on scene and
approached the house they could see the
suspect
inside the house officers made entry
into the house
and immediately saw the suspect armed
with a hammer attempting to attack the
homeowner
officers fired their weapons and the
suspect was struck
officers immediately summoned for
medical attention
and when they arrived unfortunately they
pronounced the suspect
deceased these details are very
preliminary as this is an ongoing
investigation
in the next 72 hours the sheriff or his
designee will come forward with the
press conference
releasing any updates to the case and
all bartymore body-worn camera footage
thank you sure
they're not releasing any of that yet
and then do you believe that this was an
intruder
unknown to the person yes was the alarm
go off or did the
um home owner call the police um both
the alarm did go off and a call was
placed
from the homeowner you know i don't want
to
make that comment yet because i'm not
sure but i know a call came to 911
just the homeowner and uh there was
there was two people inside the
residence other than the suspect
thank you